You're trying to do well in a class and
you get a bad grade.
Okay,
so you're in this little frame.
You want to get a good grade that isn't
happening.
He got a bad grade.
Okay,
what is it that's manifesting itself as
the bad grade?
While you could say,
well,
it's a c minus on a piece of paper.
It's like,
well,
that's,
you know,
really know that that's the objective
manifestation.
You've got a piece of paper with a c
minus the value free proposition is that
you've been delivered a piece of paper
with a curve on it and a little,
you know,
negative side.
Well,
you think,
well that's what that is.
Well,
you know it's,
it's as dopey is thinking,
well here you got your failing grade.
You go into the lab and you like weigh
it on a scale.
Then you burn it and see what it was
made of.
It's like,
well,
why did I get so upset about that?
It's just paper.
It's like,
no,
that's not just paper.
It's an entity that exists in a web of
connections.
The fact that it signified by paper is
almost completely irrelevant.
What is it?
The answer is you don't know.
And that's why when you pick it up,
you get this paralyzed,
sinking feeling because your limbic
system is a lot smarter than your
perceptual systems.
And your perceptual systems say,
well,
that's a piece of paper,
and your limbic system says,
Nah,
for sure dragon.
Right?
Right.
And so then you're sweating and then
maybe you put it away and you go play
video games because you know better the
hypothetical dragon,
then the real dragon.
And so instead you pull out the piece of
paper maybe and you think,
okay,
why did I get this c minus?
Well,
that's a hell of a question,
isn't it?
It's like,
maybe you're stupid.
Well,
that could be,
or at least stupid compared to who you
think you are.
Like that's,
that's the real horror that's lurking
there,
right?
It's like,
oh,
I thought it was kind of smart.
That's a,
that's a proposition of the highest
order.
I thought I was kind of smart.
It's like,
yeah,
well what about this c minus?
It's like,
well,
that God damn professor,
right?
That's the first thing.
It's,
it's I've been attacked by a predator.
That's the first response.
Right.
So it's,
it's a nonsensical message.
It's just delivered by someone evil and
predatory.
Well that's,
you know,
possible.
But I wouldn't go there.
I wouldn't go there first necessarily.
So,
but then,
well then say you don't go there.
Okay,
well,
so what is this exactly?
Do you not know what you thought you
knew?
Are you not who you think you are?
Do you don't work hard enough?
Are Your values not organized properly?
Do you misuse your time?
Are you in the wrong field?
Have is the way you're construing Your
Life Completely Inappropriate?
Are you acting out what your parents
wanted you to do it and you're pissed
off about it.
So you're only running at 40% to spite
them despite the fact that they're
paying $25,000 a year for your
education.
Cause that's a fun game.
Yeah,
I'll go do what you want me to do,
but I'll fail at.
But not completely because then that
would wouldn't cost you very much.
I'll just fail a little bit so that you
have to spend all that money forcing me
to do what I don't want to do,
but you'll never get to escape from it.
And then every time we interact,
I'll stab you in various ways that you
don't quite understand.
Just to show you how irritated I am that
I happened to be acting out the destiny
that you've put forward for me.
So maybe that's part of the Dragon,
right?
And then that pulls in the whole parent
thing and you know it's,
it's,
these are bottomless pits.
Often when you,
when you're in the world and it's
something objects to you,
something that matters,
objects to you,
then the in the entire unrealized world
is in that thing that objects,
it's all tangled up inside it.
That's why it's the great dragon of
chaos.
It's everything that's outside of your
conceptual structure and what is that?
It's everything that lurks outside of
your,
of your walled city.
And it's manifested itself like the
snake in the garden.
And the easiest thing to do is say,
I'm not having anything to do with that.
But the problem with that is,
well,
you get your c minus and you don't do
anything about it.
Maybe you're a little bitter and more
resentful and your study habits get a
little worse.
So the next time you get like a d plus
and then you collect a bunch of F's and
then you stopped going to school,
then he stopped showering,
right?
Then you end up jumping off the bridge.
And so that's uh,
that's,
that's how the dragon eats you when you
don't pay attention to it.
And so it's no bloody wonder that people
avoid,
you know,
it's really no wonder that they avoid,
because error messages contain within
them the implicit world.
Now the upside of that is while they
contain within them the implicit world
and the world isn't all negative,
and so maybe you get your c minus and
that's actually the best gift you ever
got because somebody finally took you
and went whack,
you know,
clue in.
And so you take that apart and you
think,
oh,
I don't know how to write.
I don't know how to think.
I've never read anything in my life.
My study habits are a Bismal,
you know,
like maybe I'm working at 2% efficiency,
which,
which is probably,
I would suspect that,
you know,
some of you aren't doing that,
but I bet you that I bet there's 30 30
to 50% of the people in the room are
working at 2% efficiency.
It's like you got it.
That's,
so,
to find that out is so optimistic.
I mean,
if you're barely hanging in there,
but you're only working at 2% you might
imagine what you could have as a life if
you work at,
at like 50% so,
so the,
the c minus can be the best gift you
ever had.
And that's the goal that the dragon
hordes,
right?
That's exactly what that means.